you were walking over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first video in a new series
based on stories from within my book new
thinking which is basically the grand
story of science and technology from the
Industrial Revolution till today
this first episode isn't something that
seems pretty commonplace and just lays
in the background of our lives but it's
actually quite cool when you look into
its history the microwave oven next time
you heat up some leftovers in your
microwave think about this next story so
in order for us to get to here we have
to start here
[Music]
it's the early 1940s and World War two
is in full swing
France has just fallen to the Nazis in
the shocking defeat and Britain was next
on Hitler's list there was no doubt
about it all efforts had to be put up to
stop the Nazis and the defeat of prison
wasn't going to be easy the row Air
Force was a highly organised machine and
had some of the best aircraft in the
world in an act of solidarity the French
Dutch Polish and even American pilots
volunteered to fight the Germans the
Italians would fight alongside the
Germans in the air it was a grueling
display of courage and sacrifice but in
the end the British and those who came
to their aid managed to fend off German
airpower Britain had been spared but for
how long an air attack had failed for
the Germans but there might be another
way to bring down Britain since Britain
was surrounded by sea and relied on
vital supplies to arrive by the ocean
and all-out Nazi assault on all incoming
ships could bring the nation to its
knees the only problem was that at this
point the British Royal Navy was the
most powerful in the world and there was
no way the Germans could compete at
least not head-to-head the answer the
night seas had to become invisible with
something called a u-boat a u-boat is
short for undersea boat in German and it
was a formidable weapon it was basically
an early form of German submarine
Winston Churchill of Britain would later
say that the German u-boat was the only
thing that scared him during the war at
this time the only way of detecting a
u-boat was visually a very difficult
task the German crafts could only be
detected when a surfaced and with
otherwise trouble underwater to torpedo
ships from a distance from the sheer
need and desperation newer technologies
had to be rapidly developed by the
Allies to help the war effort the result
of this research would be radar for the
first time it allowed the invisible to
be seen swinging warfare in a totally
new direction radar or radio detection
and ranging acts like a searchlight
here's how it works a short pulse of
microwaves which are sub optical
electromagnetic frequencies go out to a
targeted objects and reflect
back to the receiver allowing the
targeted objects distance and position
to be known
now the u-boats could be seen coming and
the Germans no longer had the element of
surprise on hand it's said by many
historians that the quick development of
radar technology during the war tipped
the balance in the scales of the Allies
meanwhile in the United States a
military company called Raytheon was the
main producer of the critical radar
equipment for the war effort
one of the components the company
produced was something called a
magnetron it was the actual device that
creates the microwaves in early 1945
Percy Spencer a Raytheon engineer was
working on improving some of the
company's magnetrons it had been a long
day's work for Spencer and his stomach
began to grumble it was time for a snack
when he reached into his pocket and
pulled out his tasty treat the engineer
was surprised to find that what had once
been a chocolate bar was now a
completely melted mess within the
wrapper at that moment he knew he had
stumbled across something big excited
Percy asked a research assistant to
bring him a bag of corn kernels when the
kernels were placed on the table near
one of the magnetrons
they began to pop it was confirmed the
microwaves used in the radar equipment
could cook food giddy with amazement the
pair tried to cook something else an egg
which probably exploded on the
assistants face so what was going on as
it turns out the microwaves gave
molecules in the food energy causing
them to vibrate rapidly and vibrating
molecules are essentially what heat is
when something is warmed up all that's
happening is the molecules that make up
the material are just vibrating at a
faster rate hence microwaves could heat
food in a totally new way if there had
never been previously possible by
vibrating food molecules directly inside
a microwave oven the magnetron similarly
transmits waves of energy but since
microwaves cannot penetrate metal they
are channelled inside a metal pipe down
into the oven cavity
since the cavity is also walled by metal
there's no place for the microwaves to
go but into the food whose molecular
structure absorb
then convert the energy in the form of
heat the American public would love an
invention that could heat up food in a
fraction of the time as the war ended
Lawrence Marshall who was CEO of
Raytheon at the time heard of Percy's
idea and thought it was great
Marshall insisted that Spencer put all
of his effort into creating a usable
product for the public it was the
perfect time for such a product because
after the war America had come away
virtually unscathed and now could enjoy
the ability to consume as many goods as
it could in a productive economy Percy
was given a team of engineers and set to
work after some time the team came up
with a product but it wasn't exactly
well portable it was the size of
refrigerator
standing 1.8 meters or 6 feet tall and
weighed 270 kilograms or 600 pounds the
Beast put out 3,000 watts of power and
was dubbed the radar range on the
information booklet it had some interest
in cooking suggestions that would seem a
little odd today a well-done steak in 50
seconds no problem fried eggs done
before you can count to 12 in 1947
Raytheon released a commercial version
that was slightly more compact for five
thousand dollars or fifty five thousand
dollars today as you could imagine this
was just too expensive for the average
person for this reason the device was
sold in restaurants and other corporate
food venues over the years it was noted
that an expensive military-grade
magnetron was overkill when it came to
just heating up some leftover chicken
gradually the microwave did reduce in
heft and by the late 1960s microwaves
had shrunk down to a form factor that we
would be familiar with today this was
accompanied with a drastic reduction in
price quality food prepared at maximum
speed there is now the perfect marriage
as in its demonstration kitchen between
the freezer and the microwave and corta
touch frozen foods and soups
vegetables and these as galloped apples
piping hot and ready to serve in a few
seconds
today the microwave is the most common
appliance in Australia with about 97% of
households owning them there are over 90
percent of homes grow
from the United States and Canada and
most Western European nations for those
wondering studies have shown that
microwaves aren't dangerous or
detrimental to the nutrient quality of
foods when they're being used correctly
as it's usually just the water within
the food that's being warmed so there
you have it from World War two to an
accidental discovery to heating up our
food for convenience
that's the intriguing and peculiar story
of the microwave anyway I hope you
enjoyed this first video of the series
if you just stumbled across this channel
feel free to subscribe this has been -
go go you've been watching cold fusion
and I'll see you again for the next
video
cheers guys have a good one
Oh
[Music]
[Music]